if you suspect in your networkers
overfitting your data that is if you
have a high variance problem one of the
first things is to try this pervy
regularization the other way to address
high variance is to get more training
data there's also quite reliable we
can't always get more training data to
be expensive get more data but adding
regularization will often help to
prevent overfitting or to reduce
variance during your network so let's
see how regularization works let's
develop these ideas using logistic
regression recall that the logistic
regression you try to minimize the cost
function J which is defined as this cost
function some of your training examples
of the losses of the individual
predictions and different examples where
you recall that wmd logistic regression
are their parameters so W is a an X
dimensional parameter vector and B is a
real number and so to add regularization
to rich it's regression what you do is
add to it this thing lambda which is
called the regularization parameter say
more about them in a second but lambda
over 2m times the norm of W squared so
here the norm of W squared is just equal
to sum from J equals 1 to NX of WJ
squared or this can also be written W
transpose W is just a squared Euclidean
norm of the parameter vector W and this
is called um l2 regularization because
here you're using the Euclidean norm all
those how the l2 norm with the parameter
vector W now why do you regular eyes
just a parameter W why don't we add
something here you know about a B as
well in practice you could do this but I
usually just omit this because if a
nuclear parameters W is usually a pretty
high dimensional parameter vector
especially the high variance problem
maybe W just as a lot of parameters so
you aren't sitting all the crown's as
well whereas B is just a single number
so almost all the parameters are in W
rather than B and if you add this last
term in
actors won't make much of the difference
because B is just one parameter out of a
very large number of parameters in
practice I usually just don't bother to
include it but you can if you want
so l2 regularization is the most common
type of regularization you might have
also heard of something to talk about a
1 regularization and that's when you had
instead of this l 2-norm you instead as
a term that is lambda over m of sum over
of this and this is also called the l1
norm of the parameter vector W so it
will subscript one down there and then I
guess whether you put M or two m in the
denominator is just a scaling constant
if you use l1 regularization then W will
end up being sparse and what that means
is that the W vector will have a lot of
zeros in it and some people say that
this can help with compressing the model
because the certain parameters are 0
then you need less memory to store the
model although I find in practice
l1 regularization to make your model
small ourselves only a little bit so I
don't think they've used that much at
least not for the purpose of compressing
your model and when people train your
networks l2 regularization is just use
much much more often so sticking up so
the notation here so one not detail
lambda here is called the regularization
parameter and usually you set this using
your development set on using hold out
cross validation when you try to write
your values and see what does the best
in terms of trading off between doing
wrong your training set versus also
setting the two norm of your parameters
to be small which helps prevent
overfitting so long there is another
hyper parameter that you might have to
chew and by the way for the program
exercises lambda is a reserved keyword
in the Python programming language so in
the program exercise you will have OMB D
without the a so it's not to clash with
the reserved keyword in Python so we use
our MD
to represent the lambda regularization
parameter so this is how you implement
l2 regularization for logistic
regression how about the neural network
in a neural network you have a cost
function there's a function of all of
your parameters W 1 V 1 2 W capital L B
capital L with capital L is the number
of layers in your network and so the
cost function is this some of the losses
summed over your M training examples and
so it's a dragon ization you add lambda
over 2m of sum over all of your
parameter W your parameter matrix of W
of there let's call the squared norm
where this norm of a matrix really the
squared norm is defined as the sum of I
sum of a J of you know each of the
elements of that matrix squared and if
you want the indices of the summation
this is sum from I equals 1 to n L minus
1 sum from J equals 1 through n L
because W is a n L minus 1 by n L
dimensional matrix where these are the
number of hidden units or number of
units and layers L minus 1 and they are
L so this matrix norm it turns out is
called the Frobenius norm of a matrix
denoted with f in the subscript so for
arcane linear algebra technical reasons
this is not called the you know l2 norm
of a matrix instead is called the
Frobenius norm of a matrix i know it
sounds like giving one edge which is
called l2 normal matrix but for really
are ten reasons that you don't need to
know by convention this is called the
Frobenius long it just means the sum of
squared of elements of a matrix so how
do you in turn gradient descent of this
previously we would compute G W you know
using back drop
we're back properly give us the partial
derivative of J with respect to W will
really W for any given L and then you
update WL as WL minus the learning rate
times D so this was before we added this
extra regularization term to the
objective now there is added this
regularization term the objective what
you do is you take DW and you add to it
lambda over m times w and then you just
compute this update same as before and
it turns out that with this new
definition of DW l this is still um you
know d this new DW l is still a correct
definition of the derivative of your
cost function with respect to your
parameters now they've added the extra
regularization term at the end and it's
for this reason that l2 regularization
is sometimes also called weight decay so
if i take this definition of yo DWO and
just plug it in here then you see that
the update is WL gives updated as WL
times the learning rate alpha at times
you know the thing from backdrop um plus
lambda over m times WL this with a minus
sign here and so this is equal to WL
minus alpha lambda over m times WL minus
alpha at times the only thing you got
from backdrop and so this term shows
that whatever the matrix WL is you're
going to make it a little bit smaller
right this is actually as if you're
taking the matrix W and you're
multiplying it by 1 minus alpha lambda
over m you're really taking the matrix W
and subtracting alpha lambda over m
times it seems like you're multiplying
to make the matrix W by this number
which is going to be a little bit less
than 1 so this is why
Oh - norm regularization is also called
weight decay because it's just like the
ordinary gradient descent where you
update W by subtracting alpha times the
original gradient gone from backdrop but
now you're also you know multiplying W
binds in some by this thing which is
more than less than one so the
alternative name for l2 regularization
is waiting K I'm not really going to use
that name but the intuition for why it's
called weight decay is that this first
term here is equal to this so you're
just multiplying the weight matrix by a
number slightly less than one so that's
how you influence l2 regularization in
your network now one question that
Pierce doctors asked me is you know hey
Andrew
why does regularization prevent
overfitting let's take a quick look at
the next video or maintain some
intuition for how regularization
prevents overfitting